hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey
you guys should green screen something
in the background we gotta make a
thumbnail for our glass review any we've
got requests to check out some Mortal
Kombat 11 stuff she shave her leash
several things so we went through the
most requested ones really three yeah
there's timestamps below for which once
or you know there's timestamps in the
pin common for the ones you guys want to
go hop to if there's a specific one okay
so we're gonna do the all fatalities and
fatal blows know what it's like to
receive a fatal blow oh if I know what
you mean hahaha I've given this official
gameplay reveal trailer and gross you
know I I'm thinking we should put all
fatalities one last yeah it seems like
sounds like the eff everyone so let's
start with a gameplay reveal then gross
Jairus Gerald Gary Gary and then we'll
all do the ho-jon what assemble the
headphone oh you bet
got my cans and all I'm for freaking did
you call Mel watch the language they
don't want to get this video team on
video with extreme violence demonetized
yeah
cool
[Music]
nice
[Music]
David
I'm looking forward to his gameplay
reveals really but I feel so just as
Savage
whoa well there's a rap music maybe put
any other truth yes like hip-hop
[Music]
[Music]
there the blood man looks gorgeous Wow
ah [ __ ] eyeball yeah like Friday the
13th for three over here the face ripoff
yeah that's tough stuff for this oh yeah
I love Shao Kahn famously became canon
after Mortal Kombat annihilation oh
that's his origin quote respond to that
comment with the utmost sincerity Jerry
mr. Garrett get geralt Gerald Gerard
Gerald's game was good
[Music]
Wow God looks like it hurts the game
oh she need all these extra things how's
this a Bobby alone
whoa you punch him in the butt I've
never played with someone who could do
all these things you're not playing with
the right people
wow that didn't finish
[Music]
oh wow I loved that graphic extra detail
of like what their core I'm noticing the
extra detail of like their body parts
are a little bit more to find when they
come flying out yeah you know yeah this
is really well animated brain yeah
early good the eyeball and stuff oh yeah
they don't skimp on the details to
really make it good
Oh shall con who has famously made
cannon after his appearance and Mortal
Kombat annihilation
oh hell yeah just like Harley Quinn and
Batman the Animated Series quote me on
that it's the truth quote me on that
cry generator for the wall we've all
just been waiting for ie
was born ready alright here we go see
that I'm just expecting that when you
hit the space bar like we're gonna zoom
in and like your bones there's gonna be
a blood geyser
[Laughter]
lady Wow
oh yeah another face look like it
reacted after nine hours just cool there
hi tube is an execution just in case
yeah Wow Oh for sticking up ladies gonna
hit him in the nuts
like nemesis it kind of looks like the
the red ether things from the [ __ ] oh I
think on the stone and what stone is
that it or the dark hole yeah oh no oh
we call that a heart attack that's
that's jarring the way he's like pushing
up like chunks of flesh ha ha
[Music]
Oh No Wow I hope when they actually get
that next movie off the ground they goes
this brutal they would wear your face is
a hat Oh take a bite out right oh wow I
love this like blood manipulation oh
yeah like blood is a weapon thing that
they're doing oh yeah
Wow Wow scar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this puts me in a positive state of mind
yeah man that really just got back from
a therapy session I feel real good and
now I'm watching we shot a divisive
mover who you went to therapy and they
watched extreme violence straight
minutes it has been a fascinating day
that's you live life man
I gotta give it to the people who make
moral Kotlik it must be fun to work for
the developer who makes these games
because you got to think that you just
have a bunch of dudes sitting around
going what's the coolest way we can Ruta
Lee murder every character grossest most
indulgent like they're so ridiculous and
over-the-top that they're like fun and
silly but also cringy and skin crawl
yeah yeah and like it's it really
doesn't seem like fun to make these even
though they're so Bruce I mean as long
as none of the creators get accused of
sexual assault I will gladly indulge in
their violent ways did that happen no
that's my point
all right this is good for Team Mortal
Kombat yeah yeah man as this makes me
just want to go find a copy of the game
well you can't you gotta wait till April
John no no pay attention to the video
well I spent yesterday on Amazon
wondering why Riverdale hadn't been
posted and I saw the shows not even
halfway done airing on the CW network so
I figure I'm licensed to get mad at
moral conduct because I can't have the
game now even though it's not
technically that's where you're a girl
that's where I was I use I did the UCB
thing where you play at the top of your
intelligence to take like a thing you
really know about and then blended into
the joke UCB is an improv theatre for
you guys took one class this is a fun
video yeah
yeah I always look forward to more
coming yeah and there's more I could do
this all day
I don't want to think that's
fundamentally what's different about our
sensibilities in terms of extreme
violence is like some of this genuinely
makes me giggle yeah yeah some of it
really makes me cringe though some of it
turns my stone I've actually learned
about myself watching this video
you know Mortal Kombat well because then
it forces you to look at these different
things and go okay this one's making me
feel actually like I'm cringing in my
skin's growth like the ones with Garris
where he's like you can tell how hard
those punches hit I'm like oh damn like
hmm but when it's like ridiculous blood
fountain air Spears I'm like this is
knowing yes shooting a guy up to a
helicopter yeah it's like so silly that
at that point I'm like I'm just having a
blast all right well hey before we wrap
this up can we give a patron the day
shout out to a man named James Dagon's
oh let's do it because I love this guy
yeah James I would love to slice off
your head and then pull out your
eyeballs throw them into your mouth and
have your head proportion right above
your body where they just send down your
open neck and then rip out your spinal
cord that and then shove it up your
butthole and have it come out your your
penis and then take you to be my face I
want to punch you in the back of the
head so your brain flies out then I'm
gonna catch it and slam dunk it then I'm
gonna land on the ground and play hacky
sack with it then I'll tell James and
I'm gonna take out a gun and I'm gonna
shove it up your butt and then I'm gonna
shoot all the way up through your body
so the rest of your head explodes into
like a blood firework yeah and then me
and the rest of the moral combat gang
are gonna sit down and watch the blood
fireworks coming out of a stump of your
neck for like ten straight minutes well
it just says flawless victory over and
over and over again and then we're gonna
talk about it at the how it should have
ended superhero calf
yeah we really got that stake ins guy
yeah we finished him you guys are really
terrible people took this video game way
too long will subscribe to reject nation
click that notification bow I'll catch
on the flippety-flip